first on CBS this morning an Olympic
swimmer is speaking out about alleged
abuse she suffered from a former team
USA coach Arianna Cukor's told police
former coach Sean Hutchison sexually
abused her and took thousands of nude
photos of her while she was a minor in
an essay she alleges Hutchison groomed
and manipulated her from age 13 she says
the abusive relationship spanned nearly
a decade as we reported last week
Homeland Security special agents
searched Hutchinson's home in Seattle
they opened an investigation with
Washington state authorities but he has
not been charged with a crime the former
Olympic coach recently stepped down as
CEO of King aquatics club after Cukor's
went public in a statement Hutchinson
writes quote I absolutely deny having
any sexual or romantic relationship with
her before she was old enough to legally
make those decisions for herself prior
to that time I did nothing to groom her
Irina Cukor's and her attorney Robert
Allard are here good morning good
morning thank you so much for being here
and Ariana I know you have said you
never thought you would share this story
why are you sharing it now I didn't
realize until a few weeks ago how
important being open and speaking my
truth was important to my healing
process and and it really has been a
journey in so many ways
I began therapy in October because I had
reached a new low point and I realized
that while I have an amazing husband and
amazing life an amazing support system
I hadn't fully faced what had happened
to me and and for so long writing what I
wrote on Friday and publishing it was a
huge step in my healing process being
able to put words to what happened to me
and and I don't think I realized until I
published it Friday just how important
that was to spread that message but not
only for myself to be able to finally
stand up and speak my truth and and say
what happened to me but the outpouring
of messages that I've received the last
few days has been so impactful and I
never thought that I would be here
sitting at this table and Ariana let's
talk about that when did this abuse
start how old were you so
when he began grooming me he started
coaching me when I was 13 years old I
would say the grooming began immediately
and there are so many definitions of
what grooming is how I understand it is
the process that a predator takes to
first psychologically take control over
you and then perhaps it turns into a
physical relationship how did he do that
so many ways I said this in my essay
every single day we had to shake his
hand and it seems like a simple nice
gesture but it's getting contact with
that person it's shaking their hand and
looking in their eyes it's you know
asking about things not only from your
swimming career but what's life like
with your family you know what are you
doing at school what are you doing this
weekend and it's creating this
relationship where you rely on this
person for everything and you go to him
for everything and so as he guided me
through this relationship of
manipulation and control he fully had
control over me and prepared me for each
step and also swimming is a one-on-one
sport and the better you do you're
rising together talk about that
relationship this isn't a team thing
this is just the two yes and you know so
I mean is known to be an individual
sport and you spend so much time and so
when there were private meetings going
on behind a closed hotel room door you
know someone might look at that and
think oh well you know they're just
discussing race tactics or strategy or
how to get better but that is
inappropriate and those kind of
conversations should not be taking place
behind closed doors how do you get to
the point where he's taking thousands of
new photos of you well so the pictures I
obviously sent him some as well he took
pictures of me both in the locker room
when I was expressed that in my essay
took pictures of me in the locker room
and you a minor then yes and those
pictures went on over a decade you told
me a story about in 2009 you won the
world you set the world record yes and
that kind of grooming in that
relationship that goes on and yeah why
that continued well I think one of the
hardest pieces may be for someone to
understand is is how this took place for
so long and this process of gaining
control over somebody I've talked to so
many parents and I've heard from so many
parents these last few days and we have
conversations with children about don't
talk to strangers
your privates are your own they should
not be touched by other people but the
conversation that I'm so hoping to have
is what happens when there's a person
that your parents see as a voice of
authority that they'd fully trust that
your family trusts that your community
is praising what happens when that
person abuses that power and takes
advantage of you and that's an important
conversation and dialogue that I hope
that we can have I I feel the most
vulnerable I've ever felt in my life in
this moment but I lift it up because of
the messages I've received the last few
days of parents saying thank you for
creating this dialogue between me and my
kids because of this I'm going home and
understanding what this looks like and
how I can talk to this with my with my
partner
talk to yourself when you said you
didn't recognize the young girl that you
were imagine another young girl is in
that position what does she need to hear
from you the message that I want to send
is that it doesn't matter what your
abuse is if it's you know there's so
many people who sent messages who said
oh my story is known as bad there's no
such thing as bad or good or less bad if
you are being abused if somebody is
taking advantage of you I want you to
know that no matter how you choose to
find your voice you will be heard and
there are so many amazing things that
are happening in this world today that
are that are open and receptive to these
conversations I want I want these people
to know that they are amazing that they
don't have to rely on these these
predators these these people who take
advantage of young people and abuse a
relationship so horrific Lee you found
yourself in this position today because
of your love for swimming do you still
love the sport do you still swim yes I
love the sport in every way that you can
imagine I've received so many messages
from teammates and coaches and friends
and people who who grew up watching my
career and and I said this in my story
that black line that that space that you
talk to and eventually that line starts
talking back I love swimming and and I'm
not here to necessarily share my story
what I'm here is to prevent this from
happening to the next person who is
trying to chase their dreams who's
trying to show up is their best self
every single day
because you don't have to rely on a man
or another human being who wants to take
responsibility for your success
who wants to be there every step of the
way and and one of the biggest biggest
things that that these predators do is
is they isolate you they single you out
the things he told me constantly where
you're the most impressive person I've
ever met
I see things in you that your sisters
don't see in you that your parents don't
see in you and because of that isolation
they put you on a pedestal and they put
you there so that nobody can help you
and I want I want people to know that
you don't have to you don't have to hear
those words to be amazing and to be
great and show up as your best self
every single day surround yourself my my
tribe of people my husband who I'm
bringing through this with me he has
been my rock and he has showed up for me
every single day because he believes in
this message he believes it's that it's
important not only for the family that
we hope to create but for the next
family for every single person who have
who has the opportunity to do this to
somebody else
Loreena it will it will make a
difference because abuse fosters in
silence and you are breaking that
silence so thank you so much for being
here and sharing your story Rob thank
you for being being here with alongside
her thank you I appreciate it